well the American media were integral to
creating the narrative that the Trump
campaign colluded with Vladimir Putin to
hacked the election no evidence of that
has come out yet
and now those same outlets pretending
the whole thing never happened they
never claimed that but that doesn't mean
they've grown uninterested in the Muller
investigation in fact they treat that
investigations efforts as sacred
even though Muller's team of lawyers
includes 13 Democrats three independents
and no Republicans unless you include
Muller himself Lee Smith is a senior
fellow at the Hudson Institute and
immediate columnist for tablet magazine
he joins us tonight so leave that the
partner whatever you think of the Russia
investigation or whatever you anticipate
we're gonna learn from it you can't deny
that the press alleged in effect
collusion for months yes it's a little
much to pretend they didn't write this
was going on well before well before the
election and went on even well before
the the story is that we know were
attributed to or believed to have come
from the steel dossier right that was
the Yahoo news piece and then the Mother
Jones piece that started in July if you
look there is a campaign and information
operation the press is already going on
prestige publications and the American
press who are going after different
figures in the Trump campaign namely
carter page the whole thing is
ridiculous and if you look at the way
they're attacking carter page it's like
no one knows who carter page is at this
point it's like they're talking about
Brzezinski or Kissinger or something
like that but so if if I were covering
the auto industry and I were repeating
uncritically every talking point GM sent
me that would not make me a journalist
that would make me basically an employee
of GM it seems like reporters are doing
that with the Intel community and with
the Muller investigation yes it's it's
actually shameful the idea that the that
the American press is working has been
working for a while with the
intelligence community taking leaks from
them many of these leaks of course are
illegal like with the the leak of
Michael Flynn exactly the way that
they're working in an information
operation along with the intelligence
community it's a horrible thing to
happen to the press and the press did it
to themselves well but you can hurt
yourself as a journalist if you're not
relentlessly skeptical and I always
thought even though journalist have
always been liberal I get it I've done
but skepticism was a thing that tied all
journalists together whatever happened
to that I think a lot of different
things have happened it's not just about
the press leaning toward the left which
is usually again that's the way the
press has always been for sure something
very different happened here and I do
believe that there will be a price to
pay
I do believe that different people once
the Russia gate narrative starts to fade
away more and more once the dasya
nonsense has gone through I believe that
people will look back and they will say
what happened here what did the
president it it was like a whole bunch
of chocolates we enjoyed it got a rust
from it but now we don't believe that we
can trust them anymore I think that's
going to be the upshot of okay I know
you're not here to talk politics but
since you live in Washington I just came
very quickly can't resist can you run a
midterm election on Russian collusion
like because the Democrats win on this
story I know whole cable shows right I
don't see how what are they gonna do
they're gonna they're gonna run against
Vladimir Putin no I think it's much more
likely the Republicans are gonna wind up
running against people like Adam Schiff
they're gonna wind up running against
people they're gonna wind up run against
people senior democratic figures who may
have played a very destructive role in
the 2016 elections and I think if we
look at the different investigations on
the hill the the Senate Judiciary
Committee and the House Intelligence
Committee it looks like their senior
Democrats who have done some very bad
things I think it doesn't look great for
them having him to do that yeah I think
they say if I were a Democrat I want to
talk about economics or really should be
very mad at at Adam Shipley thank you
that was really interesting Thanks